- [Instructor] Understanding the concept
of nonstandard free energy changes
is really important when it
comes to a chemical reaction.
For this generic chemical reaction,
the reactants turn into the products.
And nonstandard free energy
change is symbolized by delta G.
And notice, this delta G
doesn't have the naught superscript,
and therefore, it's nonstandard
change in free energy.
The reason why this
concept is so important
for a chemical reaction is by calculating
the nonstandard change in free energy,
we can figure out which direction
the net reaction will proceed.
When delta G is less than zero,
so when delta G is negative,
the forward reaction is
thermodynamically favored.
Therefore, the reactants
will turn into the products.
And the amount of products will increase,
and the amount of reactants will decrease.
When delta G is greater than zero,
so when delta G is positive,
the forward reaction is not
thermodynamically favored,
which means the reverse
reaction is favored.
So the net reaction goes
to the left to increase
the amount of reactants and
decrease the amount of products.
As long as there's a
difference in free energy
between the reactants and the products,
the net reaction will
proceed either to the left
or to the right.
However, when there's no
difference in free energy
between the reactants and the products,
or delta G is equal to zero,
the reaction is at equilibrium.
And when the reaction is at equilibrium,
the concentrations of reactants
and products remain constant.
So it's useful to think
about nonstandard change
in free energy as the driving force
for a chemical reaction.
As long as there's a
difference in free energy
between reactants and products,
the net reaction will move
one direction or the other
to the left or to the right.
However, when there's no
difference in free energy
between reactants and products,
there's no more driving force
and the reaction is at equilibrium.
Next, let's look at the equation
that relates nonstandard
change in free energy, delta G,
to standard change in free
energy, delta G naught.
Remember, the superscript naught refers
to the substances being
in their standard states
under a pressure of one atmosphere.
So delta G, or the nonstandard
change in free energy,
refers to the instantaneous difference
in free energy between the
reactants and the products.
So when that reaction moves
to the left or to the right,
this value is always changing.
It's the driving force for the reaction.
Delta G naught is a different situation.
Delta G naught is a constant
at a certain temperature.
And that's because it's
referring to the difference
in free energy between
reactants and products
in their standard states.
And so this value will remain the same
as the net reaction moves
to the left or to the right.
To calculate the nonstandard change
in free energy, delta G,
it's equal to the standard change
in free energy, delta G naught,
plus RT natural log of Q,
where R is the ideal gas constant,
T is the temperature in Kelvin,
and Q is the reaction quotient.
Next, let's calculate delta
G for a chemical reaction.
And this is the reaction for
the synthesis of ammonia gas
from nitrogen gas and hydrogen gas.
Our goal is to calculate
delta G at 25 degrees Celsius
at the moment in time
when the partial pressures
of all three gases are one atmosphere.
So one atmosphere for
nitrogen, for hydrogen,
and for ammonia.
At 25 degrees Celsius, delta
G naught for this reaction
is equal to negative 33.0
kilojoules per mole of reaction.
So our goal is to calculate delta G.
And we know delta G naught,
but we need to figure out what
Q is at this moment in time,
when the partial
pressures of all the gases
are one atmosphere.
We can get the expression
for the reaction quotient Q
from the balanced equation.
So it would be the partial
pressure of ammonia.
And since there's a two,
it'd be the partial pressure
of ammonia raised to the second power
divided by the partial
pressure of nitrogen.
And since there's a one as a coefficient
in the balanced equation,
it's the partial pressure
of nitrogen raised
to the first power,
times the partial pressure of hydrogen.
And since we have a three here,
it'd be the partial
pressure of hydrogen raised
to the third power.
Since all three gases
have a partial pressure
of one atmosphere, when
we plug in one atmosphere,
we find that Q is equal to one.
And the natural log of
one is equal to zero.
So this second term here in
our equation goes to zero.
And at this moment in time,
delta G is equal to delta G naught.
And since delta G naught is equal
to negative 33.0 kilojoules
per mole of reaction,
since delta G is negative
at this moment in time,
the reaction is thermodynamically favored
in the forward direction.
So the reactants will
react together to form
more of the products.
The reason why delta G is
equal to delta G naught
at this moment in time is because
our reactants and products
are all in their standard states.
By convention for a gas,
standard state refers to
the pure gas at a pressure
of one atmosphere.
And since all of the
partial pressures are equal
to one atmosphere, that
gave us Q is equal to one,
which made the second term equal to zero.
So only when the substances
are in their standard states
is delta G equal to delta G naught.
So if we had a different
set of partial pressures,
delta G wouldn't be
equal to delta G naught.
Let's calculate delta
G for the same reaction
at 25 degrees Celsius.
However, this time, instead
of having partial pressures
of one atmosphere, all three
gasses at this moment in time
have a partial pressure
of two atmospheres.
Let's start by calculating
the reaction quotient Q.
So when we plug in two atmospheres
for the partial pressures of our gasses,
we find that Q is equal to .25.
Next, to calculate delta G,
we need to plug everything
into our equation.
So delta G naught is still equal
to negative 33.0 kilojoules
per mole of reaction.
So we can see, we plugged that in here.
The ideal gas constant R is 8.314 joules
per Kelvin mole of reaction.
But to keep our units
the same in kilojoules,
you can see I've converted
the ideal gas constant
into kilojoules per
Kelvin mole of reaction.
So it's .008314.
We said the temperature
was 25 degrees Celsius.
So 25 plus 273 is equal to 298 Kelvin.
And the reaction quotient
Q is equal to .25.
So be the it'd natural log of .25.
So Kelvin will cancel out.
And when we do the calculation,
we find that delta G is equal
to negative 36.4 kilojoules
per mole of reaction.
Since delta G is negative
at this moment in time,
the reaction is
thermodynamically favorable
in the forward direction.
So the net reaction will move to the right
to make more products,
and to decrease the amount of reactants.
An increase in the amount
of ammonia means an increase
in the partial pressure of ammonia.
And a decrease in the amount of reactants
means a decrease in the partial pressures
of the reactants.
Therefore, when the net
reaction goes to the right,
the reaction quotient Q increases.
So we started with a relatively
small value for Q of .25.
And we know that Q is going to increase.
Let's just jump ahead to a point,
and let's say that Q is equal
to 1.0 times 10 to the third,
and let's plug that into our equation
and see what happens to delta G.
So delta G naught stays the same
at negative 33.0 kilojoules
per mole of reaction.
The ideal gas constant's the same.
The temperature's the same.
So all we've done is increase Q.
Once again, Kelvin cancels out,
and we find that delta G,
the instantaneous
difference in free energy,
is equal to negative 15.9
kilojoules per mole of reaction
at this moment in time.
Since delta G is negative, once again,
the forward reaction is favored.
So the reaction moves to the
right to increase products
and to decrease reactants.
So again, Q will continue to increase.
And think about what's
happening to delta G.
It was negative 36.4, and
now it's negative 15.9.
And as Q keeps increasing,
delta G keeps getting closer
and closer to zero.
Q will keep increasing until
delta G is equal to zero
and the reaction is at equilibrium.
So as long as Q is not equal
to the equilibrium constant K
for this reaction, the
reaction is not at equilibrium.
But eventually, Q will be equal
to the equilibrium constant K.
And if we were to plug that
value into our equation,
we would find that delta
G is equal to zero.
And therefore, the
reaction is at equilibrium.
Let's summarize the difference between
the nonstandard change
in free energy, delta G,
and the standard change in
free energy, delta G naught.
Delta G naught is talking
about the difference
in free energy between
reactants and products
when reactants and products
are in their standard states.
And since that value is a constant,
if the temperature is constant,
notice for all of our calculations,
delta G naught was equal
to negative 33.0 kilojoules
per mole of reaction.
Delta G is talking about
the instantaneous difference
in free energy between
reactants and products.
And as long as there's a
difference in free energy,
there's a driving force
for the net reaction
to go to the left or to the right.
And eventually, when
delta G is equal to zero,
the reaction is at equilibrium.
Delta G is only equal to delta G naught
when the reactants and products
are in their standard states.